which one of these is impossible oh uh
damn honestly i cannot tell
both smell really good
[Music]
we've used garlic onion powder salt and
pepper
i'm going to shape these this real meat
into patties i don't really know what
i'm doing so i'm kind of just
shaping it into a disc the impossible
meat feels kind of like
i don't know like chunky a little bit
more grainy i'm hoping that the texture
ends up feeling better once we shape it
into patties
possible meat is super sustainable it
uses
96 percent less land 87 less
water and creates 89 percent less
emissions than power
tomato little bit of lettuce and voila
i'm hallie i'm a producer at buzzfeed
and i've been trying to eat less
meat recently so i wanted to share some
of these plant-based recipes with my
friends who do eat meat
and see if it's something that they
could tell with not real meat and
whether it was something that they would
be interested in trying again in the
future
all right i'm gonna start with this one
here on the left i'm gonna make a guess
right now
and say that this is the real stuff like
if you look at that color
you know i'm really not sure but i think
this is the impossible one i kind of
like looked at the shape of the patty
but it's still got that like really nice
color on the inside and like a crust on
the outside this one's definitely a
little bigger
but they both look just as tasty this
one just had some juices fall both of
them have some juices falling out
[Music]
you don't have to like it it's okay i do
like it i like it but
to be honest this looked better and i
would eat it if someone handed it to me
but just red meat is just sorry guys
sorry planet these burgers are well
done exactly the way that lindsay likes
them because
she's a freak right off the bat i
do think this one is the plant-based one
though
this one they're like so well done i
like don't even know
actually no maybe i'm wrong
let me see i think i do prefer
the impossible burger i don't love to
like
beef flavoring to begin with like that
extra
bloody fatty flavor i'm not a huge fan
of
a little too much a little too much cow
for you yeah a little too much cow for
me
it still thinks it's really good you put
this in front of me i will eat that
whole thing and i will eat this whole
thing
um i gotta go with the classic
beef burger which is a little more juicy
actually i think i like
the one that i think is plant-based i
think i like this one better
i think this one holds more flavor
and i think it's the plant-based one am
i wrong
you're right
liz what'd you just say so i have to
admit
that my opinion changed after i had to
sit with it for a while
because i have like stomach problems and
it just felt like the meatless one
went down way better than usual meat
goes down in my stomach
so all right i'm not paying her to say
that i promise
i actually want to go back to this one
this is delicious
[Music]
when i'm hooked wow this is our meat
loving friend you like it
spoiler alert this is the plant-based
one it's so good
i'm so glad you like it it's kind of
like nutty
it's like a burger but also it's
elevated
elevated would you would you make these
again at home
well yes
i win 100 you don't have to go full
vegan it's okay
um i'm not vegan i i still love cheese
and dairy and like
i haven't yet transitioned to veganism
but that's okay like
just cutting back is a huge help for the
[Music]
environment
[Music]
you